>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: DO YOU REMEMBER HOW WE
WERE TOLD TIME AND AGAIN THAT IT
WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP DAMAGING THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR CHERISHED
INSTITUTIONS?
>> IS THE PRESIDENT THREATENING
THE LONG-STANDING INDEPENDENCE
OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> HIS CAMPAIGN TO UNDERMINE THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION AND THE
FBI.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
UNDER A SHELLING FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
IT'S LIKE LONDON IN 1941 THERE.
>> AN ASSAULT ON THE RULE OF LAW
UNDERMINING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI IN WAYS
THAT ARE SHOCKING.
>> Laura: OKAY.
WELL, NOW THE SHOE IS SQUARELY
ON THE OTHER FOOT.
WHAT WE JUST LEARNED IN THE PAST
48 HOURS.
McCABE THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
ASKED FOR CONGRESSIONAL IMMUNITY
FOR FURTHER TESTIMONY.
THE DOJ GENERAL REPORT FOUND
THAT COMEY WAS INSUBORDINATE AND
CRITICIZED HIS HANDLING OF THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION AND
THE REPORT CASTS DOUBTS ON
LORETTA LYNCH IN THAT SAME
INVESTIGATION AND HER TARMAC
MEETING WITH BILL CLINTON.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH A FORMER
SECRET SERVE AGENT AND A
PRESIDENT OF JUDICIAL WATCH AND
JEFF WHO SERVED IN THE FBI AND
THE CIA.
TOM, IT'S SOMETHING TO HEAR THAT
LITANY OF SOUND BITES WITH THE
GRAND EXAGGERATION.
IT'S LIKE BOMBING LONDON.
COME ON!
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE GENERAL
REPORT, THE LITTLE DRIBS, AN FBI
MISHANDLED THIS INVESTIGATION
AND DIDN'T CONSULT WITH
SUPERIORS AND DEFIED PROTOCOL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP INHERITED A
TERRIBLY CORRUPT LEADERSHIP AT
THE FBI AND CLEANED HOUSE BY
FIRING COMEY.
HE DID THE RIGHT THING.
THEY CAME TO THE SAME CONCLUSION
ABOUT THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
ITSELF, BUT HE ATTACKED HILLARY
CLINTON TO DISTRACT FROM THE
FACT HE WAS HELPING HER.
THE IG TORE HIM APART.
>> Laura: DAN, THE DEVELOPMENTS
TODAY.
A LOT OF COMMENTS FROM PEOPLE
THAT WERE MENTIONED AND
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ABLE
TO COMMENT.
PERHAPS IT WILL BE CHANGED.
YOUR INITIAL REACTION OF WHAT WE
ARE HEARING.
>> WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE JAMES
COMEY WILL BE EXPOSED FOR THE
PHONEY HE WAS.
HE HID THIS INVESTIGATION FROM
CONGRESS FOR 8 MONTHS.
JUST SO EVERYBODY IS CLEAR ON
THIS, THERE IS A PROTOCOL FOR
QUARTERLY BRIEFINGS TO CONGRESS
ABOUT SENSITIVE INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY ASKED HIM, EVERY 3 MONTHS,
THIS IS NOT DIFFICULT FOR
ANYBODY TO UNDERSTAND.
HE HIDES IT FOR 8 MONTHS.
MR. COMEY, WHY DID YOU HIDE THE
INVESTIGATION FROM CONGRESS FOR
8 MONTHS?
YOU WILL NEVER BELIEVE THIS.
BECAUSE IT WAS SENSITIVE.
AFTER ACKNOWLEDGING THEY BRIEFED
CONGRESS EVERY 3 MONTHS BECAUSE
OF SENSITIVE INVESTIGATIONS.
I AM TALKING ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION OF DONALD TRUMP.
COMEY IS BEING EXPOSED.
HORRIBLE LEADERSHIP.
I HOPE THIS IG REPORT GETS THE
TRUTH OUT THERE.
>> Laura: YOUR FORMER EXPERIENCE
WITH THE FBI AND THE CIA.
THE RANK-AND-FILE AGENTS IN THE
FBI THEY DON'T MAKE A TON OF
MONEY AND WORK REALLY HARD AND
PUT THEIR LIVES IN DANGER EVERY
DAY.
WHAT DO THEY THINK?
I TRY TO PUT MYSELF IN THEIR
SHOES.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING WHEN THEY
SEE THE CIRCUS AROUND THIS
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION AND THE COLLUSION
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND TRUMP THAT
SEEMS NONEXISTENT.
DATES NOT MATCHING UP.
WHAT IS GOING THROUGH THEIR
MINDS?
>> YOU KNOW THEY HAVE TO BE
DISAPPOINTED.
COMEY, I DON'T BELIEVE HE EVER
WAS AN FBI AGENT.
HE WAS AN ATTORNEY.
HE HASN'T COME UP THROUGH THE
RANKS.
CONTRAST TO AT THE CIA HASKELL
WHO CAME UP THROUGH THE RANKS.
ONE OF THE UNDER LYING THINGS IS
WHERE ARE THE WHISTLE BLOWERS
HERE?
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THERE ARE
NOT RANK-AND-FILE WHISTLE
PLOWERS COMING FORWARD.
THERE IS A PAY SYSTEM IN THE
FBI.
THEY DON'T GET THE BEST BASE
PAY.
A SYSTEM REWARDS THEM WITH 25%
OF THEIR BASE PAY.
IT CAME LAW ENFORCEMENT
AVAILABILITY PAY.
THE FBI AGENTS HAVE TO CERTIFY
THAT ADDITIONAL TIME HAS BEEN
WORKED.
50 HOUR WEEKS OR MORE.
SOMETIMES THESE CORNERS ARE CUT.
A GREAT LOOK OUT THERE CALLED
"FRAUD FIGHTERS," WRITTEN BY A
FORMER FBI AGENT AND TALKS ABOUT
FRAUD AND THE SUPERVISORS
CERTIFY THIS TIME WAS WORKED.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SAYING THEY
ARE NOT WHISTLE BLOWERS BECAUSE
THEY ARE AFRAID THEY WILL GET
DOCKED PAY?
>> WELL, THEY HAD TO SIGN EXTRA
NON-DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS.
THEY PUT THE FEAR OF GOD INTO
THEM FORCING THEM TO SIGN THESE
AGREEMENTS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THE IG LEAK IS UNDERMINES THE
COMEY INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
GONE DAY 1.
THAT'S ONE OF THE FEW THINGS
TRUMP COULD HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
>> THIS WAS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
ANTI-CORRUPTION ACT BY A
PRESIDENT IN RECENT MEMORY.
[OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Laura: DAN, WHY IS ROB
ROSENSTEIN STILL SUPERVISING
MUELLER WHEN HE IS GOING TO BE A
WITNESS?
HE IS A WITNESS HAVING SIGNED A
FISA WARRANT THAT DID NOT REVEAL
THAT HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR
THAT FIELD DOSSIER.
LINDSEY GRAHAM WAS ALL OVER THIS
AND SAID I WILL RECUSE MYSELF.
HE SHOULD NOT BE EXERCISING
MUELLER.
>> LAURA, NOT ONLY THAT.
NOT ONLY DID ROSENSTEIN SIGN A
FISA WARRANT.
HE IS A MATERIAL WITNESS IN THE
FIRING OF JIM COMEY WHICH THE
DEMOCRATS ALLEGE WAS THE
GREATEST SIN OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
ROSENSTEIN IS IMPLICATED IN SPY
GATE AND HOW HE IS STILL ACTING
AS THE DEPARTMENT IG IS ONE OF
THE GREAT MYSTERIES.
>> Laura: I WORKED WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT AND
THE EDUCATION DEPARTMENT AND IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE UNDER-SECRETARY POSITIONS
ARE SO IMPORTANT.
YOU HAVE BAD PEOPLE YOU FOR BIG
TROUBLE.
JEFF, REACT TO PAUL RYAN TODAY
IN HIS WEEKLY PRESS CONFERENCE
JUMPED ON THE GAUDY SPY WAGON.
LET'S WATCH.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> [MUFFLED AUDIO.
>> I DON'T LIKE TO COMMENT, LET
ME SAY IT THIS WAY.
I THINK HIS INITIAL ASSESSMENTS
ARE ACCURATE BUT HAVE MORE
DIGING TO DO.
>> Laura: THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
A LOT OF DOCUMENTS ARE MISSING.
NO SPY.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> WELL, MY REACTION IS THIS HAS
ALWAYS BEEN 2 DIFFERENT
APROACHES.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS APPARATUS WAS
PENETRATED BY PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
THIS COUNTRY THE FBI WARNED THEM
TOGETHER.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY THEY HANDLED
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE OF THE COIN.
THEY DECIDED TO GO AHEAD AND
CALL IT ENTRAPMENT.
THEY DIDN'T GO INTO THEM AS
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND SAY,
LISTEN, WE HAVE FOREIGN ENTITS
TRYING TO PENETRATE THIS AND
CORRUPT THE PROCESS.
THEY HANDLED THE REPUBLICANS